plutôt clairs ou foncés toutes les peaux
ne sont pas égales sous le soleil
pourtant aucune n'est totalement protégé
contre les brûlures
ni les mélanomes ces cancers de la peau
ont augmenté de 100% depuis 40 ans en
martinique
et comme le risque est décuplée si les
coups de soleil surviennent avant l'âge
adulte
des mesures s'imposent à tous j'estime
qu'ils sont déjà exposés quand ils
sortent de la maison
donc du coup quand on va à la mer c'est
indispensable de mettre de la crème ils
n'ont pas les peaux très blanche et
malgré tout je les remets du 50
c'est vrai qu'à l'école par contre je
crois qu'il les protège pas les enfants
malformés tennis
enfin intervenir mais je crois pas qu'il
les protège au sein même quand ils
jouent dans la cour les enfants et
rentre avec des coups de soleil alors
entre des coups de sommation les protège
pas et là ils ont eu leur crème ce matin
ce matin j'aurais dû renouveler mais
pour l'instant à londres donc je vais
pas revenir encore où est ce que la
maîtresse d'école pense à eux à l'école
nous ont franchi quand même beaucoup à
l'expérience
il faudra effectivement soit les
sensibiliser et les enfants que saft il
sur le risque encouru et quelles sont
leurs habitudes au quotidien
une étude a été lancée en avril auprès
de 300 écoliers dans une vingtaine
d'écoles du sud en cabinet on constate
des coups de soleil qui sont si bien à
la plage qu'à l'école donc on s'est posé
la question comment améliorer c'est état
de santé surtout qu'on sait que les
coups de soleil dans l'enfance et
l'adolescence prédispose au cancer de la
peau dans le questionnaire rempli par
les enfants il ressort qu'à la plage six
enfants sur 10 mettre de la crème
solaire mais ne renouvelle pas
l'opération un sur quatre seulement
porte une casquette un sur trois a des
lunettes de soleil et un sur deux est
protégé par un lycra ou un tee shirt et
dans les autres activités de plein air
la protection est encore moindre quand
on a questionné donc de façon factuelle
est ce que vous aviez déjà eu des coups
de soleil 40,8 pour cent des enfants
répondez oui j'ai déjà eu des coups de
soleil dans les six derniers mois et
dans les coups de soleil
on peut avoir des coups de soleil grave
et il y avait 6 % qui avait eu des coups
de soleil grave donc le coup de soleil g
c'est quand on a des cloques ont été
hospitalisés ont été obligés de prendre
des médicaments et dans 6 6% donc de
coups de soleil grave il y avait 10 pour
cent dix enfants à peau claire et 6 à
profusion donc ça montre aussi de
clichés de se dire je suis antillais
avec une peau foncée donc je suis
protégé du soleil certains facteurs de
protection messaâd facteur de protection
relatif dans un an les mêmes questions
seront posées aux écoliers pour vérifier
si les habitudes ont changé
l'objectif à très court terme est
d'apprendre aux enfants dès l'école à se
protéger des uv une campagne à concevoir
avec le rectorat et la rs car notre il
présente toute l'année des conditions
d'ensoleillement extrême et le mélanome
est une maladie potentiellement mortelle